最近気づいたんだぽけもんがこのようにねってことになるこのようにポケモンなんてい
ねえ事に気付いちゃってハトし私は最近ポケモンカードで遊んでいるのですがを疑問
カードで遊んだ異なるポケモントレーダーの方ならわかると思うんですけども疑問カー
ンってこうポケモンが技をしちゃうんですよ流行ったりと
ひっかくアイル放射とかすると相手のポケモンにダメージが
いるんですよダメージの計算をするためにダメージカウンター
略して打面ランというものがございますどんなものかといいますとこちらですねはい
こういうやつですね
脱ぎみたいで美味しそうなんですけどもまぁ10点度50点の100点のホリエモンが
ダメージを喰らった時に乗せるカウンターが入ってます私これ知ってんだなーすげー
綺麗なんだ
保木梶普通に遊んでいる人はまあこれ一袋
持ってるんですけどもめっちゃ綺麗ですね結構見た目好きなんだよね派としては
あれこれ一袋にどれぐらいっていうかというと中ダメ館が24戸
50度名鑑な店高脚ため感が3個ということでこれ一袋で版って9位
ダメ自分入っておりますだかと師は話しは思ったのですもしですよポケモンカードも
ですけどもポケモンでどんどんぽ強いのが出てくるかもしれないんで一袋だと890
ダメージですけども文字ですよ2000ダメージ3000ダメージ
ダメージがどんどん良いフレッシュって世界絶滅破壊光線 gx z みたいな技を
打って相手に何か6900ダメンズとか
与えたらもうダメカーン890点だと足りないんですよだめか890だけ自分が足り
なくなってくるというわけで今回ですね
瓶燗を100万円分ズームしますいや回転にちょっと分けわかんないかつになって
しまったんですけども
こんなんで240袋入っております何で倒伏に890ダメージも入ってるんで890時
の240は213,600ダメージつまり伊久間で213,600ダメージなんでこれ
が釣れず3つこれ3つで64800ダメージ
大名鑑が入っているんですつまりポケモンカードのポケモンが強すぎで64万ダメージ
が出てもこれさえあれば他入れるというわけでございます出していきましょう
はっはっは
立っています
上場右腕はすごいダメージ量だ
[音楽]
はっはっは
声やバイオ5用
いやもうやばいよこれやばいよ
んだった
あっはい
はいというわけでを基本が起きかでは頭を食らって10万ダメージ受けた時にポケモン
カードでこれだけの大メーカーを載せなければいけません
とりあえず全部出しまあ
バッハ
敗2分けでダメが20万だめじゃんとこれぐらいになることが分かりました
5足していきましょう
[音楽]
やっぱりで40段た例自分のため考えました
やっ
[音楽]
re
ずうずうダメージすごいで様子でもうここまで来ると笑っちゃいますね
もうちょっとこのまま時計のようになるかどうかわからないですけど60万ダメージ分
まで乗せてみようと思いました
[音楽]
はい取り上げでダメ元60万だね自分でました
もうね結構付いっぱいはもとかだったんですけどもギャ守りになるくらいにはなってき
ました
俺今64万800ダメージでございますまあも力にすごい強いポケモンカードが出て
攻撃
体当たり64貼ってるダメって言ったらカードにこれぐらいのため考えると思っ
てくださいああ
ああああああ
me
[音楽]
ん
i0全部出し終わりましためっちゃくちゃで買い込み箱が結構
あります相手で100万円分の誰かを出しておりました
5時間半かかりましたここにあればが多いんですけど
ここ+こんな醸すああああこんなかも全部食べ感ですからね
アメリカンと数計算したんですよ逆に泉南ダメージ分のダメージカウンターがありまし
た
ちょっと山にしたようにスッと出してみようかないきます
[音楽]
これぞは山に出来ませんねというでハトシどうしてこんなにダメージカウンターを準備
したかと言いますとこれは思ったんではポケモンカードで戦ってるポケモンたちは舞
太鼓のだめが置かれてい大ダメージを負っているわけですよそれがたとえ中のページで
も曲ダメージでも線ダメージでも痛いんですよ何なのに俺たちポケモントレーナーは
そんなポケモンを得た見よ
ああああああ
わかっちゃいないそんなを本当に時もそれなんでいいのか
てがこの波戸氏はポケモンカード等で続けているため館の痛み
技を受けるダメージの痛みは好みやとって受けてみたいと思った今年どういう月上で
今年私は今から500万円分の約2000万大名城実際に受けてみて
ポケモンたちがいつもどれくらい痛い覚え寄せた
分かってるんだぞその身をもって体感してみようと思いますとレッスン入りまーす
[音楽]
やばいな4
やばいはじゃないよ誰かーえっ
たっ風
ha じゃないどっダメや晴れ
米5 a
[音楽]
[拍手]
ai
goo
あああああ
[音楽]
ブーブーいる
ダメージその2000万ダメージ分 ok だ時ブーブー言っちゃあ
[音楽]
ポケモンをいつもこんな怖いんだよみんなダメージ受けるとにポケモンは強いんだよ
ちょっと5分ぐらいから実はいいつもいボウワーク行くなってよし
いきますお願いします水
全1
[音楽]
ん
気絶
me
dea
ana あああっ
えいえー
[音楽]
うわぁ合わせうわぁ
ああああああ
ハマダイコンちゃんねるマッハ抜けこういう感じのですねー
んまぁそこそこいてえわとまぁあのポケモンだってもいつも痛い思いしで戦ってるんで
みんな呼吸かもね
大切にしてあげてください
ん
[音楽]
いいえ
やばっ